die alkoholindustrie verweist an dieser
stelle gern darauf dass sie ja
freiwillig über die risiken des
alkoholkonsums aufgeklärt
wir schalten wir live indie harald
juhnke gesamtschule in berlin neukölln
dort veranstaltet nämlich sebastian
pufpaff vom bundesverband der deutschen
spirituosen industrie gerade ein seminar
genommen präventionsarbeit ist so
wichtig herr welke
man muss kinder fühlen so auf mich an
das thema alkohol heran für reden aber
auch machen ich mache hier zum beispiel
gerade einen kleinen test mit dem gips
was schmeckt euch besser whisky cola
oder ein broker sauerkraut move it move
it loud in selbst es müssen die kinder
sich entscheiden und das ankreuzen
eigenverantwortung herberge auf wer
bedeutend bei uns wir wollen mündige
trinkern kinder bürger über mitmenschen
und das ist prävention
wir hatten brauchen jetzt auch gar nicht
nur zu gucken ja also wir von der trink-
und weg vereinigung machen so viele
freiwillige uns hat noch nie einer danke
gesagt und wir klären auch auf jeder
deutschen bierflasche hier
ich habe den beweis gibt es dieses
riesen schild kann man näher dran noch
näher noch mehr da steht wir bewusst
genießen und wenn man noch mehr rand
wird noch ganz ganz nahe steht
leider geben
[Applaus]
hat
kino kino schulz wir haben uns gedacht
ich den spaß und auch beim herrgott es
ist ja eh schon alles nur überreguliert
in diesem juni starb laut gesetz dürfen
wir uns in der werbung noch nicht mehr
direkt an kinder wenden warum das ja
fast rassismus und wir hatten so schöne
plakate vorbereitet hier zwar viele
kaffee trinken trinken und natürlich
trotz der braumeister jetzt alle
wegschmeißen und das ist ja auch nicht
umweltfreundlich wie gesagt wir machen
wahnsinnig viel die alkoholindustrie
finanziert sogar ein eigenes
forschungszentrum um herauszufinden wie
gesund alkohol wirklich ist und ich will
dich super dass wir die notenpresse
unsere ergebnisse immer brav
veröffentlicht eine flasche wein pro tag
gesund biertrinken gegen krieg jeder tag
ohne wein kann ein herzinfarkt risiko
sein
brandgefährlich sonntag ohne weinhofer
können sie von stern und was wir auch
aus gefunden haben aber auch schon eine
flasche aquavit deckt den tagesbedarf
eines erwachsenen an aquavit es gewusst
nein das wusste nicht wer welche bildung
bildung ist so wichtig auch kinder
gerade sitzt ja schon wieder auf dem
trockenen
danach mit dem becher mal wieder ein
voll oder was meinst du gewinnst 13 oder
kommt heute auch nicht in pink bringt
marita koch war auch meine da moderne
[Applaus]